ich suche einen neuen Cutter die so
weshalb und warum werde ich euch gleich
erzählen aber erstmal muss ich Eric
zurückholen weil wir kochen gemeinsam
etwas
bleibt hier ja sollen wir einkaufen
gehen
ganz ehrlich zu sein eric hat seine
Sachen nur für unseren gemeinsamen
Amerika Urlaub gepackt aber wir suchen
wirklich einen Cutter ihr fragt euch
vielleicht warum
als erstes gehen wir einkaufen
[Musik]
vielleicht könnt ihr schon raten worum
es heute geht was wir kochen aber eine
wichtige Sache ist schon dabei die
Schnitzel von Vales weil es unterstützt
das heutige Video und einiges was wir in
Zukunft Vorhaben werden
weiter geht's nächster Station Asia
Supermarkt
[Musik]
spätestens jetzt dürftet ihr wissen was
wir machen wir machen heute Rahmen
selbst
[Musik]
so und jetzt können wir endlich kochen
und das machen wir jetzt auch weil es
hat mir gesagt ich soll mir was schönes
überlegen was wir kochen können und das
habe ich ich bin wirklich sehr sehr
proud und glaube es wird extrem lecker
was wir machen wir haben drei
verschiedene Produkte geschickt
Schnitzel Schnitzel mit Gouda und crispy
Sticks wir nehmen heute die normalen
Schnitzel wenn die schönen goldbraune
anbraten und dann wie Katze in unsere
Rahmen einlegen ich glaube das wird
richtig lecker ich habe ohne Spaß die
Dinger hier schon ganz oft gekauft ganz
oft gegessen finde ich wirklich sehr
sehr gut wir brauchen heute nur den
Klassiker die Schnitzel als unseren cut
zu Ersatz den wir in die Rahmen einlegen
werden die anderen Speichen für wann
anders auf aber das wird safe lecker
also ich habe mich schon selbst ganz
häufig geholt deshalb habe ich mir auch
wirklich gefreut dass sie für eine
Kampagne angefragt haben und die rosten
als erstes mal unseren weißen Sesam an
zack um noch mehr Farbe diese frische
reinzubekommen es gibt einige Sachen die
wir vorbereiten müssen und einige
Herausforderungen zum Beispiel brauchen
wir diese perfekten weichgekochten
Rahmen Eier wobei wir nicht die
klassischen Rahmen Eier machen werden
weil die halt irgendwie zwei Tage
eingelegt werden wir machen einfach ein
perfektes weichgekochtes Ei wir machen
unsere Brühe selbst mit mesopaste und
haben da eine creamy Miso Rahmen raus
mit Kokosmilch wir haben noch nie Rahmen
gemacht genau das kommt noch dazu aber
noch nie gemacht deshalb wird es umso
spannender wir nehmen uns unseren Bräter
die kriegen schön Farbe wir nehmen ein
wenig Erdnussöl das sind den Topf und
dazu kommen zwei fein geschnittene
Schalotten dazu geben wir geriebenen
Ingwer und 7 10 gehackten Knoblauch
alleine jetzt weiß man schon da wird so
viel Geschmack drin sein wie das riecht
ne Ingwer Zwiebel gefährlich gefährliche
Kombination boah wirklich der Geruch zu
krank wie das so ineinander kommt riech
mal bitte das geht auch so in die Augen
und so boah das knallt richtig an der
Knoblauch knallt richtig das hat richtig
Power wir gehen eine gute Prise Zucker
noch mit dazu und das Ganze so ein
bisschen zu karamellisieren jetzt hat
auch der Sesam die gewünschte Farbe
immer mit sicherheitshandschuhen Kochen
auch ganz wichtig allein jetzt bin ich
schon froh weil ich habe diesen Geruch
noch nie selbst erschaffen in einer
Küche
unseren Sesam den wir frisch angeröstet
haben reiben wir jetzt in unserem Mörser
der sollte wenn alles gut geht für einer
Paste werden das sieht nicht verkehrt
aus das riecht auch so lecker asiatische
Küche haben wir wirklich so wenig bisher
gemacht die steht uns noch komplett
offen ne weil man gar keine Ahnung
darüber hat wo man weiß es schmeckt
unnormal lecker ja aber man hat auch das
Gefühl dass da so viele Geheimnisse drin
steckt und man macht man schafft es
immer nur so eine Touri Version zu
machen aber ich glaube heute sind wir
auf einem guten Weg unser Zucker ist
perfekt geschmolzen jetzt geben wir den
frisch geriebenen Sesam dazu vermengen
das ganze ein bisschen und jetzt rote
gereifte Miso Paste so einfach wie das
war sind wir eigentlich am Ende von
unserer Brühe angekommen wir gießen das
ganze nämlich jetzt mit einem Liter
Gemüsebrühe auf
zack zu dem Zeitpunkt verrühren wir
einfach nur noch das alles sich schön
auflöst das sieht schon super aus ne
guck mal rein sieht richtig gut aus
richtig schön trüb die Sesamkörner
schwimmen darin und die Brühe sieht
schon sehr gut aus aber mit den noch
drüber sein noch cremiger deshalb geben
wir jetzt noch 150 Milliliter Kokosmilch
dazu
mit der Kokosmilch lassen wir das einmal
kurz aufköcheln dann stellen wir es nur
noch runter und halten die Brühe bereit
dieses Eisbad ist für unsere perfekten
weich gekochten Eier hoffentlich werden
sie perfekt die wir jetzt ins kochende
Wasser geben und zwar für 7 Minuten und
wir nehmen uns ein Soßen Topf machen den
warm und geben Butter rein die wir jetzt
leicht braun werden lassen wir die
Plancha heiß werden bzw freuen uns dass
sie noch heiß ist nimm ein wenig
Erdnussöl und geben unseren Pak Choi
darauf einfach nur um auf der
Schnittkante so ein bisschen Farbe dran
zu bekommen den wenig zu garen ich mag
das eigentlich gerne wenn er noch
ordentlich bis hat wenn der Pak Choi so
aussieht bisschen Farbe bekommen hat
legen wir ihn hier rüber zack aber
unsere plansch aber brauchen wir gleich
noch für die Schnitzel wir ein bisschen
Öl um die ballettschnitzel perfekt zu
braten braten wir Sie bei mittlerer
Hitze Plan schaut noch ein bisschen heat
red
wenn unsere Schnitzel zum ersten Mal oh
ja das wird geil die Schnitzel braten
die Butter wird langsam braun das ist
für uns unser Stichwort den Herd
auszustellen und Mais dazu zu geben
damit dieser frischen gebräunten Butter
schmeckt er noch mal doppelt so gut wie
er sowieso schon schmeckt okay Timer
fertig das heißt für Zeit unsere Eier zu
holen sie behutsam das Eisbad zu legen
und die letzten beiden die müssen ja
nicht krass Abkühlen sondern ein zwei
Minuten damit sich Schale sich einfach
besser löst und wir sie perfekt pellen
können jetzt gehen wir noch unsere
rahmnudeln in das Wasser zack Nudeln
abkippen
zwei perfekte Portionen fertig machen
erstmal Pelle ich jetzt die Eier sind
noch ein bisschen warm einfach rundum so
ein bisschen aufknacksen das finde ich
mit so die größte Kunst so zumindest
sieht das immer so aus wenn Rahmen
gemacht werden vorsichtig das ganze
abziehen das ist uns ein bisschen
abgebrochen oder damit können wir den
Test machen oh so habe ich mir gewünscht
seht ihr wie schön dieses Eigelb ist wie
cremig das bleibt das Interessante ist
wenn man jetzt die echten Rahmen Eier
macht dann nimmt man die einfach so und
gibt die in Gemisch aus Sojasoße und
anderen Zutaten der Garpunkt bleibt aber
der gleiche weil man die Garung stoppt
indem man die in das Eisbad gibt
das ist
goldbraun crunchy
nicht so das diese faserigkeit innen
drin sieht sehr sehr gut aus wirklich
das ist ein perfektes Produkt für diese
Rahmen richtig hier so aufgeschnitten
die Katze was willst du mehr das gleich
so an der Seite einlegen perfekt schaut
euch diese wunderbaren Zutaten an und
ich würde sagen wir können anrichten
[Musik]
zu dir noch einen Tee für die Nerven
gemacht weil jetzt wird es ernst Leute
wir haben eine wunderbare Kreation
geschaffen bin ich wirklich also Erik
und ich haben uns das gemeinsam überlegt
ich bin rundum zufrieden ich finde das
ist ein Traum ja ich probiere
die Brühe ist krank ja die brös wirklich
krass Augen von der Chili Paste die noch
drauf gekommen bin dieser buttrige Mais
hast du schon mal die Schnitzel gegessen
noch nie okay dann sag mir erstmal bitte
ehrlich wenn du ein bisschen was davon
mit Brühe nimmst wie es sich für dich
macht als Ersatz
Ernst krank oder vor allen Dingen die
Textur die Textur ist krass also der
Geschmack dass das der Geschmack halt
sehr nah ankommt gerade bei Hähnchen das
kennt man ja schon von dem ein oder
anderen Produkt aber ich finde gerade
hier die Textur also das was man sehen
konnte diese Fahrsicherheit die spürt
man halt auch wirklich auf der Zunge und
das ist halt krank wir sind ja beide
regelmäßige Fleischesser also ne und wir
mögen es auch gerne Fleisch essen aber
ich finde hier so von der Vollmundigkeit
in so einem Löffel Brühe dazu das
Schnitzel also dann vermisst nichts ja
das genau das wollte ich gerade sagen so
ja der Titel war ja am Anfang etwas
clickbaity würde ich jetzt mal nennen ja
aber er ist real so wir rauchen
Verstärkung ja wir haben gemerkt ihr die
Videos über die letzten Wochen gesehen
wir haben eigentlich an allen Ecken und
Enden versucht eine Schippe draufzulegen
so also wir haben in der neuen Küche
neue Motivation gefunden es hat
überhaupt nichts mit dem letzten Video
zu tun wenn ich sage dass wir einen
neuen Cutter brauchen weil Eric da sind
wir uns bestimmt einig muss weiter auf
diesem Kanal hier sein also Eric wie ihr
in wahrnehmen hinter der Kamera mit
seinen sehr geistreichen Einwänden und
so die wir alle gerne hören die bleiben
so alles bleibt in der Hinsicht gleich
wir haben uns einfach gedacht wir sind
gerade so am Gas geben am optimieren wir
wollen noch mehr Zeit in die
Vorbereitung aufwendigere Videos einfach
mehr Gas geben und vor allem Eric soll
voll dabei sein so dass mit Sicherheit
weil Eric ja auch nicht nur meinen Kanal
macht sondern ein Unternehmen hat zu
wenig Zeit sein wird um den Videos die
Aufmerksamkeit zu geben die wir Ihnen
zukommen lassen wollen ja und das
funktioniert zum einen deswegen nicht
weil ich auch noch andere Dinge mache
aber auch einfach weil die Videos in der
Aufwendigkeit immer aufwendiger werden
und der Schnitt gleichzeitig mitwächst
also ihr müsst euch vorstellen wenn wir
jetzt früher ein Video an einem Tag
gedreht haben dann drehen wir das jetzt
mindestens an zwei Tagen und dann ist
auch der Schnitt nicht mehr an einem Tag
möglich sondern auch in mindestens
anderthalb bis zwei Tagen in der
Frequenz wie wir die Videos aufnehmen
wir produzieren eigentlich sofern wir
nicht in den Urlaub fliegen nie krass
vor das heißt wir sind immer aktuell wir
haben höchstens mal an einem Montag was
für Donnerstag gedreht und dann an dem
Mittwoch was für Sonntag und so arbeiten
wir uns so wollen wir auch weiterhin
arbeiten um aktuell zu bleiben um
frische Ideen direkt umzusetzen man den
heißen Themen so dran zu sein und dafür
braucht man da halt die Möglichkeit wenn
man Montag dreht dann direkt die Sachen
in den Schnitt zu geben die direkt
verarbeitet werden und wir können uns an
dem Dienstag direkt für das
sonntagsvideo noch mal irgendwohin auf
dem Weg machen irgendeine andere krasse
Sache machen ja und halt so nicht nur
die Videoqualität an sich sondern auch
die Inhalte noch geiler aufzubereiten
und es geht gar nicht nur um
irgendwelche Storytelling Inhalte weil
ich finde Storytelling ist ganz nice was
wir machen es geht auch einfach um
visuelle Geschichten es geht um
Einblendungen
Animationen die übelst geil wären aber
die einfach zeitlich nicht drin sind in
dem Rhythmus indem wir gerade arbeiten
ja wir werden testfotage vielleicht von
diesem Video vielleicht von einem
anderen Video für euch in der
Videobeschreibung verlinken so dass ihr
euch damit einfach austoben könnt zeigen
könnt dass ihr Videos schneiden könnt
dass ihr Videos aufwerten könnt so mehr
als das was vielleicht da ist
reinschneiden könnt weil genau das
brauchen wir suchen wir wir haben eine
E-Mail-Adresse eingerichtet an die könnt
ihr einfach eure Einsendung schicken wir
gucken uns das alles an einfach am
besten mit einem nicht gelisteten
Youtube Video oder so und melden uns bei
Euch wenn Ihr vielleicht die Person seid
die in Zukunft die Videos schneiden wird
und genau und wie Max gerade schon
gesagt hat geht es wirklich darum
kreativ zu werden versucht wirklich was
hinzuzufügen den ein oder anderen Twist
mit einzubringen traut euch auch
vielleicht etwas zu machen was wir
vorher noch nie gemacht haben weil ihr
denkt dass das gut ist dass das Video
aufwerten würde also ganz ehrlich wenn
wir jetzt ein Video abgeliefert bekommen
was uns komplett von den Socken haut
dann richten wir uns flexibel so ein
dann können wir remote Arbeiten du
kannst nach Köln kommen das ganz egal
aber zeigt einfach was hier drauf habt
wenn wir das suchen was ihr drauf habt
dann finden wir schon Einigung das wird
auch ein neuer step auf dem Kanal sein
weil wir haben ja noch einige Sachen im
Auto genau auch in im Hinblick darauf
natürlich
zu viel spoilern aber wir brauchen auf
jeden Fall Unterstützung für die Zukunft
herzliches Dankeschön nochmal an Vales
dass sie dieses Video unterstützt haben
ich habe zu Beginn gesagt dass sie auch
zukünftige Projekte unterstützen werden
hier ist ein für euch vorgeschlagenes
Video schreibt einfach mal Danke Eric in
die Kommentare boah finde ich schön
schreib das mal alle in die Kommentare
wir freuen uns auf eure Einsendung bis
zum nächsten Video macht's gut und ciao